combien d'entre nous peuvent se souvenir d'un
moment d'enfance où nous avons vécu le bonheur comme
un état d'être ce moment où
tout dans notre monde allait bien
il était une fois un jeune
psychiatre appelé Hector nous avons été très
rassurés par ses schémas prévisibles
regardez ma vie  regarde ma vie ma vie es-
tu heureux tu es en train de sortir de moi
n'est-ce pas oh tu ne vas pas
juste poser une question comme ça tu dois y
arriver je ne rends pas mes
patients plus heureux je  besoin de faire des
recherches sur quel bonheur eh bien tu
penses que tu vas dans ce voyage d'
Ellen
Je pensais Chine Chine génial
tu vas le faire fais le
totalement recherche d'amour je veux savoir
ce qui rend les gens heureux un verre est
incassable incassable
[Musique]
hé je suis en Afrique salut
tu es là pour sauver la planète plante
des arbres combien de temps seras-tu parti
je ne sais pas seras-tu là quand je
reviendrai quand je  peut parler de la question pas
plus importante pour eux mais nous sommes s
rechercher est ce que nous évitons dis moi ce que
tu veux tu n'as qu'à décider ferme
nous échappe, nous
ne devrions pas nous préoccuper tant
de la poursuite du bonheur que
du bonheur de la poursuite
[Musique]
Oh
toi